Hello. And we are now live.
Hello, Jason. How are you?
I'm doing good. How are you doing today?
I'm very well. Thank you. I'm excited.
I'm I'm really looking forward to today's session.
So for people that are tuning in,
we are going to cover
Kubernetes deployments using the Cluster API
on bare metal compute using Packet host.
Now I know a few of those words,
which is really cool. And I'm expecting Jason
here who now we're colleagues. We work together
at Packet as of, what, two weeks ago
now?
I think this is my third week. So
Third week. Yeah. It's
it's gone fast, but it's been fun.
Awesome.
So do
if you don't mind, can you just
explain to me what Kubernetes is? I will
do that to you. What Cluster API
what the Cluster API is? Let's assume I'm
okay with Kubernetes and and
So Cluster API is basically
a way
of declarative
declaratively defining Kubernetes
clusters
using Kubernetes primitives.
So,
you know, basically,
when the project was started,
you know, we decided that, you know, we
have this declarative system for defining,
you know, basically applications and running them.
Wouldn't it be great if we could also,
you know, define infrastructure this way
and manage
the Kubernetes clusters themselves this way? So that's
kind of what,
you know,
started Cluster API as a project
was taking those declarative concepts that you get
in Kubernetes and moving them over to
not just infrastructure management,
but specifically managing Kubernetes clusters themselves.
And that includes, you know,
basically, the entire life cycle of a Kubernetes
cluster from installation
to
ongoing operation. You would wanna scale the cluster
up, scale the cluster down
to upgrades,
and then tearing those clusters down when you're
done with them.
Okay. So that so I can define a
Kubernetes cluster instead of Kubernetes cluster to get
a Kubernetes cluster?
Yes. Right. Awesome.
So I guess my first question there is,
is this a
I I mean, when I first started using
Kubernetes, the model seemed to be that we
or at least maybe it's the organizations I
was working with. We had one cluster to
rule them all. Like, one massive cluster, we
ran all of our workloads on it.
And is that not best practice anymore? Is
the cluster API
a sign that we should have smaller many
clusters many smaller clusters?
So I think there are varying use cases
depending on your workload, what you're trying to
get out of the workload that will determine,
you know, how big of a Kubernetes cluster
are you running.
You know, are you specifically trying to
fully optimize your resources to the maximum to
get maximum bin packing for your applications?
In that case, it makes sense to run
a really large cluster
and run everything in that one cluster because
you can get kind of the best resource
utilization
for your applications that way.
However, it also creates basically a singular failure
domain around that Kubernetes cluster.
So even though you would loo if you
lose the control plane of a Kubernetes cluster,
you generally still have your applications running in
there,
but you'd lose the ability to manage those
applications.
You know, you can't scale those applications to
meet demand. You can't push updates to those
applications if the control plane is down. So,
you know, being able to, you know, spin
up multiple Kubernetes clusters
allows you to create much smaller failure domains
around
the clusters themselves.
And in the past, it was pretty prohibitive
to have many small clusters
mainly because, you know, installing
and managing the life cycle of those clusters
was a very labor intensive process.
And if you can declaratively
define those clusters and manage them,
then it's much easier to spin up and
tear down clusters as you need them.
Okay.
So
I write a manifest. We're gonna walk through
all of this. So, you know, if you're
tuned in, you can you can watch me
make a mess of this or hopefully be
successful.
But I write a manifest to spin up
a Kubernetes cluster.
Now
the state of that cluster, I'm assuming, is
stored within the controller cluster.
Is that using Kubernetes primitives as well, like
secrets, or how how does that work?
Yeah. So
we generally have the concept of a management
cluster with
Cluster API, and that's basically just a Kubernetes
cluster that is running the Cluster API controllers
themselves.
And
that will store kind of the external state
of the cluster, you know, what cloud provider
resources
you're using for that cluster, how many
nodes you have in that cluster, what's the
state of the control plane, which version is
that control plane,
things like that.
The actual state for the workload clusters themselves,
which we, you know, we refer to the
clusters that are managed by cluster APIs, workload
cluster,
that's stored within the etcd
cluster that's present inside that cluster itself.
So, you know, if the management cluster goes
away
for any reason,
you know, the clusters are still fully functional
and the control plans for those clusters are
still fully functional.
The only thing that you really lose is
the ability to
manage the individual clusters until you restore that
management cluster.
So that makes me think. I mean, could
I use a GitOps model for the management
cluster to be able to tear that down
and restore that relatively
painlessly?
Absolutely.
That was the idea behind
driving a declarative model was,
you know, people already have
methods of storing, you know, declarative resources,
whether it's more traditional configuration management like Puppet
Chef or
even CF engine or or using
a more cloud native model like GitOps,
you know, they can use those same
tools to manage Kubernetes clusters with Cluster API.
Awesome.
Alright. Subjective question. Is Cluster API the best
way to deploy a new cluster?
And I will say, you know, it really
depends on your use cases.
There are some folks that are already using
other tooling that exists,
in which case, you know, that's something that
their group knows already.
It generally makes sense to, you know, continue
using what you know if you're happy with
it.
If you are searching for something new, I
would suggest at least exploring Cluster API.
And what we're seeing is is,
you know, when we built Cluster API, we
didn't necessarily build it as
the end user interface,
you know, for installing Kubernetes clusters. It's not
an easy button necessarily to Kubernetes.
The idea was specifically around trying to build
something that higher level tooling could
build upon to kind of create those easy
button installers.
And we're starting to see adoption
for,
know, other tooling with Cluster API.
For example,
you know,
there there's actually,
you know, Kubernetes products on the market today
that run based on Cluster API on the
back end.
Okay. That's
really cool.
We already have our first question from a
familiar face, so I'm gonna drop that in.
From Daniel Fennerin,
why do we think the Cluster API came
about? What were the issues with existing tooling?
And he mentions KubeSpray as an example.
So there were various different issues depending on
which tool you're talking about. And I don't
necessarily wanna pick on any specific tool because
all of these tools came about because of
specific needs that weren't met at the time.
But one of the challenges is is that
a lot of the tooling may be very
specific with how you need to run it.
You need to use a specific type
of configuration
management tool to manage your clusters.
Or,
you know, it was a very they have
very imperative models. You have to run the
installer. You have to run the upgrader,
and you have to build if you want
to have declarative management, you would have to
build that around the tooling.
So, you know, the idea with Cluster API
was specifically
not being overly opinionated
in those areas
so that it can be used in a
more general purpose fashion
and, ideally, would gain adoption from those more
kind of opinionated tools.
Okay. Right. I'm excited. I'm definitely interested to
see how far I can get along here.
So
what we're gonna do now is we're gonna
just use the documentation.
I'm gonna do my best to walk through
these steps. I have your wonderful guidance as
I go. What I would suggest to anyone
who's watching, if you have questions, you can
drop them into YouTube,
Twitter, or Twitch, and we will do our
best to answer them as we go.
So let's
pop open my screen.
We are gonna deploy on Packet today. There
is a Packet provider for the Cluster API.
I always see that shortened to CAPI. Do
we call it CAPI?
So it's it's a challenge because
if we, you know,
call out the long name, it's it's really
a mouthful. And if you say it a
lot of times as we generally do in
meetings,
So we generally like to abbreviate it to,
you know, a shorter way to say things
when we're, you know, among folks that are
commonly working on it.
But,
you know, it's really about the context. I
I try not to abbreviate it if I'm
not speaking to folks that I know already
understand the abbreviations.
That's a good rule. I like that rule.
Alright. So we have here the Cluster API
book.
But I think we've covered the why,
Cluster API. So let's go straight to the
quick start.
Alright. So the only things I need to
get started are
cube control
and
some version of Docker and Kubernetes.
So I am prepared.
And,
hopefully,
we have cube control one eighteen, client state,
and cube control one sixteen.
And trust me if they ship with the
beta, but one sixteen dot six beta zero.
So that is okay. Right? You're happy with
that that version requirement.
Yes.
Awesome. And the only reason why we have
a requirement on one sixteen is because we're
specifically using
CRD based resources if, you know,
if it wasn't for that, you know, there
wouldn't be a real minimum version.
Yeah. Okay. Good to know.
Next,
we need cluster
cluster
control. I was gonna say cluster CTL, but
then I say cube control, and I am
confusing myself. So cluster control, I'm gonna call
it. That's I've I've never committed that. So
and I need to just confirm that that
works,
and I'm good. And are any minimum requirements
I need for this? Or zero three eight,
am I good to go?
That should be good to go. The only
thing with the specific version is is it
might affect which, you know, defaults it uses.
But 038,
I believe, is the latest release.
Okay. Is my text large enough on that
screen? Do you think it should be bigger?
It probably wouldn't hurt to make it a
little bit bigger.
Alright. Let's go with that.
So
task one, initialize
a management cluster.
Oh,
and we have instructions for packet. I
wonder if that's a real API token or
someone just made that out.
If I remember correctly,
it was just a random string that was
added for the purpose of the documentation.
Okay. Good. Good call to make on the
text bigger. We've already had a thank you
from Lewis. Thank you, Lewis.
Right. So
now because this is a livestream, and I
don't want to expose any keys,
I need
to
I did this before,
but let's do again.
And I'm going to run
the edit command.
So I'm assuming that when I run cluster
control in a
infrastructure packet,
So does that mean the providers are all
baked in to cluster control,
or is that gonna download some binaries behind
the scenes? What what's happening when I run
this command?
So by default, what it's going to do
is it's going to reach out on
the Internet to GitHub releases for the various
related
providers. So there's more than one type of
provider in Cluster API.
We have the infrastructure provider, which in this
case is Packet.
It will reach out to the cluster API
provider packet repo,
inspect the releases,
look for the latest compatible
version of the packet provider
that is compatible with this version of cluster
cuddle, cluster control,
whatever we wanna call it. And it will
also do the same for the core cluster
API components
and
the bootstrap provider and the control plane provider,
which if you don't specify in this case,
will default to kubeadm.
Alright. Okay. So this is gonna use q
d kubeadm
under the
just because I'm a curious individual.
I'm gonna run a get paused on all
namespaces.
And just so I can see what's happening
on this cluster when
we have the management or control plan.
Management cluster. Yeah. Let's do that.
Oh, it says install in manager as well.
It is installing cert manager, and the main
purpose there is is because each of
the different providers is actually a set of
Kubernetes controllers
that also have webhooks for providing validation,
defaulting,
and, in some cases, API version conversions.
Start manager automates
the certificate management for those components.
I got it. Okay.
Cool. So
that was
pretty quick.
That was
much quicker than I was expecting.
That's good. So I'm gonna have to
okay. So do we have our
own
namespace for everything we just created there?
There will be a few different namespaces depending
on the provider. Each provider is deployed in
its own namespace to avoid
kind of issues because we allow
specifying providers that aren't known upfront. So anybody
can kinda create their own Cluster API provider,
and we wanted to limit the ability of
that you know, any provider deployed from accessing
data from other providers.
Okay. That makes sense.
So cert manager, you've you've kind of covered
there. We've got the CAPI webhook system,
push up system control plan, and then the
packet setting. So
here One of the
of the things that may not
make a whole lot of sense to begin
with is the fact that we have a
separate webhook
namespace.
And that's mainly because
at the current time, the multitenancy
model for Cluster API is
deploying those resources per namespace.
And if you have API conversion webhooks,
you can't specify on a CRD multiple
webhooks or conversions
to be able to work with that kind
of namespace multitenancy model.
So all of the webhooks exist in one
namespace,
have no RBAC defined. So they can only
operate on the input that they're given and
provide the the expected output. They can't actually
query additional resources.
We are working for the future to build
in kind of native multitenancy,
which will then move the webhooks into,
you know, the same namespace as the providers.
So is that
multitenancy
and that
say, have two different teams
deploying onto packet. Would they be able to
deploy two different packet providers to the cluster?
Or Yeah.
So there's,
you know, there's the use case of separating,
you know, different users being able to create,
you know, and manage different clusters.
But then there's also you can provide you
know, if you deploy two different packet providers,
you can point them at different credentials
for each of the providers, and then you
have,
you know, the ability to use multiple accounts
with Cluster API that way.
Okay. Cool.
Alright. Let's see what we got next then.
So our install went fine, and now we
want to create our first cluster.
So if I run cluster control
config
cluster,
I will get some YAML back?
Yes.
So, basically,
the the idea of this command is is
that each of the providers publishes
kind of a generic
set of templates
that can be used and
define
certain variables that they expect the user to
replace for
kind of common kind of cluster deployments.
This command basically reaches out
the same way to GitHub releases,
inspects the
cluster templates that are published for the provider,
and, you know, allows you to do the
variable substitution
and output that to a YAML file that
you can then feed in to create the
cluster.
Cool.
Right. Let's see what happened. Oh,
unexpected argument.
I'm assuming, potentially, like, a cluster name?
Yes.
Okay.
So
we will call this
livestream cluster.
And this is where you see the variables
that are published for the provider.
We recently added support for setting defaults for
some of these variables, but that,
we haven't added that to the packet provider
yet. We're looking to add that shortly.
Okay. So I can, according to this message,
either use environment variables or a cluster control
config
fail.
I I think I like the sound of
a fail
better. Oh, we have documentation tools.
So
is there a example of the fail approach?
I don't think so,
off the top of my head. If I'm
not mistaken,
it's just,
an I and I based definition
similar to what you see with the environment
variables.
Alright. Well, I'm
not brave enough to try and see if
that works. So what I'll do is build
the
end virus dot x h,
and I'll just source it when I run.
So
do I need
You'll probably wanna replace that project ID with
the correct project ID.
I'm kinda tempted to try it, to be
honest. I mean,
it looks almost legit. Like like well, maybe
yeah. Almost legit. Okay.
So let's get this done.
That's not secret, so we can just grab
that from here.
Yeah. That is the same format. I think
that was a legit project ID. I'm sure
it doesn't exist anymore, and no one can
use it. It's just same as the key.
Am I deployed to Likely, if you wanna
be able to access this cluster afterwards, you
might wanna set the SSH key too.
But I know you know how to recover,
you know, from that scenario anyway.
Yes. We could. But I'll I'll try oh,
yeah. So this is just gonna be a
public key. Right? Okay.
Fidelity Amsterdam one, I'm gonna go with the
node operating system.
And I'm assuming not every operating system is
gonna be supported because that's the same support
as q b d d the q b
d m, I would imagine.
There is that bit, and there's also a
bit of
expectation on the packet provider with how we're
doing the bootstrapping today that
it expects to be
at least Debian, if not, Ubuntu. So we
probably don't wanna change that.
Okay.
Let's get my public key.
That SSH key is actually going to be
an SSH key name that's defined in packet.
Oh, of course, it will be. Right. Okay.
We can delete test here. I'm sure that
won't break anything.
Okay.
So not my public key. It's the name,
which is that.
I don't need to modify the pod or
service CIDRs.
And depending on availability in and one, those
may or may not be available. So let's
just quickly
check first.
New
on demand.
T one smalls. When they're listed here, I
generally find that's a good indicator that they're
available, so we should be okay.
So I need to run
this again,
but first, I have to source
Kubernetes version.
And
if you go back to the quick start,
some of these,
some of the variables that are exposed can
actually be specified as command line arguments to
cluster cuddle config itself.
So if you just scroll down a little
bit,
you'll see the example also includes the Kubernetes
version
and the number of, control plane machines to
use as well
and
the worker machine count, which defaults to zero.
Okay. Well, with today being the 01/19 release
date, do you think it's gonna work?
I would not guarantee it.
There there's also
the the way that we're bootstrapping right now
also has a little bit of impact on
this, and
some of the work that we're doing with
the packet provider is to kind of get
it up to speed with some of the
other providers that are out there.
So I think that, you know, the the
Kubernetes version that we define here doesn't actually
impact the packet provider today.
Okay. Got it.
Okay. So we wanna run
this command again, and we're gonna specify
those flags.
There we go.
Alright.
So let's save this.
My stream
cluster.
Yeah. No.
Because this wrote it to copy quick start.
So I'm assuming
we're we're not actually created cluster yet. That's
just to configure it.
K. Yes.
It'll be this next command when you actually
run the
cube cuddle, cube CTL apply that you'll actually
create the cluster.
Okay.
Let's do that then. So
apply dash f livestream
cluster.
Too easy.
Now
one of the things you can do is
you can do cube cube cuddle get cluster
dash API,
and it will actually give you all of
the cluster API resources
that are defined.
Oh, okay. Alright. Okay. So
we have
some
okay. So we got four different
cube admin, QBD, and context. We got one
for the control plan,
each for worker nodes,
conflict template.
I'm not sure what that is.
We have our machine deployment.
So that's In in some cases, we have
kind of template resources, and that QBATM config
template is
one of those. It's attached to
a machine deployment resource,
and it kind of stamps out individual
kubeadm configs for each of the individual machines
that it creates.
Okay. So this is the template, and then
I can actually see here by the naming
that each of the worker nodes is using
that template. Mean, so I could have multiple
templates
to deploy different
like, if I wanted to have different node
groups, node pills, whatever they're called, where I
have
three t one small workers and then 12
c one large arms or something like that,
those would be templated machines. Right?
Those would be more around the infrastructure templates.
The kubeadm config templates are going to impact
kind of the kubeadm config that's fed into
bootstrapping.
So whether it's the initial nodes and taints
and annotations
for a specific node or if you wanted
to specify different
kind of
cloud provider or,
you know, anything, you know, specific to the
kubatem config.
Interesting.
Could I
using Cluster API, have a cluster that spans
more than one cloud provider?
Technically, you probably could create one. I wouldn't
necessarily recommend it just because
the,
you know, the way that the cloud controller
managers work,
they don't necessarily
play nice around those scenarios,
especially when you look at some of the
behavior like
deleting instances
if it can't find
a node resource related to it or, you
know, the other way around. It'll delete a
node resource if,
you know,
you know, it doesn't see one for it.
Yeah. That makes sense. Even halfway through that
question when I was asking that, I realized
I'm about how bad an idea that would
be.
Alright. So we got our control plane machines
now. So there's some vocabulary here then. Right?
So we have machine deployment,
machine
a machine
set.
Yeah.
There is a machine set.
If you think about kind of some of
the existing Kubernetes concepts that that you know,
you have a pod, which is roughly equivalent
to a machine in Cluster API.
And then building on top of that machine,
we have machine sets,
which basically manages multiple replicas
of, you know, machines
similarly
to how a replica set manages multiple pods.
And then on top of that, you have
the machine deployment
that kind of manages a declarative config
across different replica sets
or machine sets similar to the way that
a Kubernetes deployment manages replica sets.
So I'm curious. Like, you know, could I
modify the replicas on this machine set demo?
Would would that work? Would that spin up
a new machine?
It would, but I would recommend doing that
on the machine deployment, not the machine set.
Otherwise, the machine deployment would go back.
Oh, so it's the same hierarchy then. Like,
a deployment to replica set. This is a
machine deployment to machine set. Right? Exactly.
Okay.
And because I'm curious
go ahead. And they also expose the
the scale sub resource so you can actually
use
cube cuddle, cube control scale
to scale the machine deployments and control planes.
Oh, sweet. That's pretty cool.
Alright. I'm just gonna save that then.
I can run
Clip CTL
get Cluster API again.
And I'm gonna oh, there we go. Oh,
so these are all pending. I think we've
had
I bet you that machine type is not
gonna be available after all.
So the reason why they're pending right now
is because the control plane is not fully
ready yet
because Cluster API doesn't current currently
automatically manage
the CNI provider.
So if you jump back to the quick
start, you'll see there's a step to
deploy a CNI provider.
But first, you'll actually need to retrieve the
cube config for the cluster.
And then once you deploy the CNI provider,
everything else will spin up.
Alright. So I'm just getting two ego then.
You tell them I just looked at it.
Got it. Alright. So let's just do all
the command that tells me to do. So
I run get cluster all namespaces.
Does my livestream cluster?
Cool.
And then we wanna make sure the control
plan is up.
Replicas
updated unavailable.
So is that still maybe just provisioning behind
the scenes, or is that an error I
can ignore?
So one of the things we can do
is we can look up the
the packet machines.
So if we do you can just do
the kubectl get
cluster API again, and we can just look
at those packet machines, and then that will
tell us where in the process we are.
Or any way for me to use, like,
the kubectl logs command to get event information
or to the describe command to
to debug this? We do
do publish events. You could you can run
kubectl get events, or
you could go into the the actual logs.
We try to avoid
requiring users to do that just because there's
a lot of verbose information that
is really hard to parse.
We've been trying to move more towards conditions
on the individual
resources
to
provide user facing information.
Okay.
That makes sense.
So the phase on our
machine control play as provisioning. So I guess
we just
be patient.
Yep. And if I had to guess right
now,
the machine's probably still bootstrapping.
I just like looking at things. I'm just
gonna
start describing things and see what's going on.
So I think you're right. It's probably still
bit strapping.
I mean, I trust you.
Alright. So these are IP addresses. I mean,
I guess, theory, I could SSH onto this
machine. I could start running PS. I'd be
looking for the usual candidates. I guess, there's
gonna be, like,
Qibla, maybe the API server process, etcetera. So
or I could be patient, and we could
talk about something else as well.
And and, basically, what we're doing when we
bootstrap the machines, we're injecting a Cloudinet config
into the user data.
And in the case of the packet provider,
it's actually downloading
all of the dependencies.
So it's downloading Docker. It's downloading,
you know, the Kubernetes binaries and installing those.
So it takes a little bit longer than
some of the other providers at this time.
Yeah. We can take a look at that.
So there is an endpoint we can hit.
Metadata.packet.net
slash user data, which will actually show us
that provisioning script.
We got some key configuration.
These are all generated by cert manager. Right?
Those ones are actually generated by
the Cluster API Bootstrap.
Well, no, the control plane provider
to generate the CAs that are used during
the
provisioning process.
K. And then we get a
cube ADM
configuration.
Let's go by cluster name,
Kubernetes version,
And those are actual provisioning steps then.
Yep. And those are the actual steps that
we're adding in for the packet provider to
kind of
work around the fact that we don't have
a prebaked image to use for Cluster API
at this time.
So is there
if not now, you know, hypothetically, whether it'd
be in three or six months, but this
is using Docker. It's the runtime implementation. Is
there the option to swap that out for
container d or something else?
So in general, for Cluster API, there's a
Kubernetes
SIGs project
image builder,
and we generally bake pre bake the images
for the various cloud providers. We haven't gotten
a packet added to that yet.
But when we do, that project already defaults
to using container d. Oh, sweet. Good.
So if I wanna see how far along
this is,
then
Probably the easiest way would be to, just
inspect the Cloudinet logs.
So if you look at specifically,
varlog,
Cloudinet-output.log,
I think.
Oopsie.
That looks bad.
Oh, you know what?
Is it a good what or a bad
what?
Well, I'm
so So it looks like it's trying to
start Kubernetes/admin.com.
Let's take a look at the other
Cloudinet log.
Yep. Okay.
So let's open that.
Log.
I'm wondering if we're hitting an issue because
maybe the 01/19
release is out.
I don't know if no. That can't be
the right version because that's 01/19/2011.
So I just Yeah. That's it in it.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah. So what you were saying when
we ran the the provision and step the
YAML generation step was to take Kubernetes version
as ignored by the packet provider for now?
Mhmm. Yeah. Okay. Got it.
Well, sort of. So it's fed into the
kubeadm
bootstrapping
config.
So if we look at
we can check to see that file on
disk. I would expect that to be I
think it's written into a temp directory.
So where should I go? Sorry.
Let's go back to that,
the the user data script.
Ah, yeah. Okay. So
so if we look at that, we're, you
know, making sure the swap's off. You know,
we're
getting those packages. We we can check to
see if, you know, we actually completed any
of those steps.
Yep. Yeah. Docker. It looks like it got
past Docker. So we can
assuming the ping is unlikely to cause any
errors. So
well, we just run the try to rerun
that. Yep. Yeah.
Badly, we're on the same page.
Ah, okay. Yeah. So
So so it was that Kubernetes version we
specified that that got us.
Yeah. So, yeah, the cubelet is one eighteen
eight. The control plane is one seventeen three.
So should we just tear this down and
provision with one eighteen eight? Would that fix
it?
So let's
try something something different. Let's go in and
just modify the resources to be one eighteen
eight.
Okay. So there's gonna be two places. There's
gonna be the cube ADM control plane, and
then there's going to be, the machine deployment
that we have defined.
Can I
modify
an Earth generated YAML and reapply? Would that
work?
Yeah. That that would work, or you can
just, kubectl edit the actual resources.
What you wanna do? It's your call.
Edit resources?
Yeah. Why not?
Alright. So we're gonna modify.
Should we do the control plane first or
the machine deployments?
The control plane is the one that's hanging
up right now. So well,
yeah, let's go ahead and do that one.
The demo, we have to fix the machine
deployments really, really quickly, or do we have
a better time?
We'll we'll have time. Alright. Okay. So we
want to
I'm gonna run get cluster API again. So
what we want to change
is
the control.
No. You're gonna is it the cluster?
No.
It'll be it's down at the bottom of
the screen.
There you go. This one here? Yes.
Okay.
It could be the end control plan.
Livestream.
If I search for 1.seventeen,
not in the annotations,
and we want 118Dot8.
Right?
Yep. That's the word. The error message we
see in
the logs.
So I'm that going to shut
down this machine and reprovision in Newborn?
So, actually, we're gonna end up in a
weird situation here specifically around the control plane.
That's alright. I think we're
Well, the problem is is because we've already
technically attempted to initialize the control plane,
we won't actually try to reinitialize
the control plane with the change.
And that's basically to
prevent the situation where somebody accidentally scales down
their control plane to zero and then scaled
it back up. We didn't wanna present the
situation where
somebody thinks that their cluster is healthy,
but they've just wiped out all the data
of their cluster.
Okay.
That sounds like a good thing, which is
good. Yeah.
So what's our what's our next step here?
So we we may want to go ahead
and delete this cluster and start over with
that in mind.
Delete. Delete. Delete. Okay. I think that's fine.
So I am going to modify this, and
we do have a question.
So
Adrian has asked, can I provide a custom
Cloud configuration?
Yes. So you can definitely specify
additions to the Cloud Init configuration if you're
using the default Cube ATM control plane.
You can specify any of the,
you know, kubeadm configuration itself. You can specify
commands to run before
the kubeadm and it'll join command is run,
and you can specify some other kind of
Cloudinet specific things around
users, NTP servers,
SSH keys, things like that.
Cool.
So
I think what's happening now
is it's still deleting the old one. So
when I apply the new one, we're gonna
have a better delay. So in order to
speed this up, what I'm gonna do is
if we run this again
with different name,
that should still just start spinning up. It's
still waiting on the old one to delete.
Exactly.
Okay. But I'm now gonna have to replace
1Dot17Dot3
and 118 again.
Apply.
I don't know why I keep typing it
in. I never did that. Alright. Okay.
Now if I run get
q
a d m control
plans,
and we're just gonna have to wait a
moment or two while that machine gets provisioned
and the cloud and it kicks in again.
There we go. Cool.
I guess we can jump back to the
quick start just now and assume
that besides our little version on full path,
that things are gonna spin up quite nicely
for us.
So next, we need to
deploy a networking solution.
And, yeah, basically, we're gonna have to wait
until the workload cluster
control plane is available
because
in order to deploy the CNI, you have
to deploy it against the cluster itself.
Yeah. That that that makes perfect sense. So
it seems from this documentation here that I'm
assuming I can use any CNI, and Calico
here is just
a default suggestion?
So if you're running through the quick start
with the default configuration,
Calico is known to work. So if you
looked the
pod CIDR that we specified
when we created the cluster
with the environment variables
is also the same default as Calico uses.
If you are using a different CNI, you
may have to modify that or potentially some
other
Qubitium configuration
to work with that CNI provider.
Okay.
Is that something you see that would potentially
be added to cluster control in the future
where I could specify the CNI and it
tweak the generated channel in some way?
Like, would it know? Or as you think
that's at the scope for cluster control.
So it's one of the things that we're
looking at kind of longer term. How do
we incorporate
with, you know, different,
you know, deployments that we don't necessarily want
to manage the life cycle of specifically in
Cluster API?
So right now, there's a new feature
that you can use to just specify arbitrary
YAML to deploy at runtime.
But longer term, we're looking at how can
we align with projects like the cluster add
ons project
and
use something like that for managing the life
cycle of
things like CNI.
But then even longer term, how can we
leverage projects like that to expose
some of these things that may need to
be modified
or that we may need to modify in
the
Cluster API side to
help enable some of this stuff. So right
now, you need to manage that stuff externally,
but we're looking longer term, you know, how
can we investigate ways to kind of automate
some of that complexity in the future. And
we don't necessarily have the answers for how
that's gonna happen yet,
but but it is something that we want
to help solve for users.
Do you see this as something that
would potentially package up into, like, a Helm
chart or use it in JSON or anything
like that to distribute
prebaked configurations?
Potentially,
with the kind of
cluster resource set feature that's there for deploying
arbitrary YAML,
if that exposed
specific,
you know, environment variables,
you know, that we can use for
kind of replacement in similar ways that we're
using on the cluster template,
you know, today,
you can do something similar to that right
now. But you would kinda have to predict,
you know, all of the various permutations
with that right now.
So
maybe.
I
I don't know what those are gonna you
know, how that integration's gonna look. But if
anybody listening has ideas, please come and present
them.
Okay.
Cool. Let's keep an eye on that space
then.
So I'm not worried. I I'm sure this
is gonna be available shortly.
But
should we jump onto this machine and and
check CloudEdit for
just to Yeah. Prove that it worked. Right?
Like I said, I'm not worried.
Mhmm.
Let's see.
Okay. So it's at the docker step.
QVDM is running.
That's a good sign.
Yep. So we can probably tell that Cloudinet
out We have a kiblet.
Yeah. Yeah. We yeah. We can we can
go tell that log.
Or I can just keep correcting until I
see more and more cubes in front of
me.
Okay. Let's do it the proper way.
So
right now, it's deploying a static manifest.
That's awesome.
Our control plane is happy.
Yep.
That QB to enjoy command for public IP
address and token should probably disappear.
It's a good thing this is a short
lived cluster. Right?
Why can I not take?
Did my machine disappear?
Close.
Not sure if I lost my connection or
not, but I'll just ignore it. I'm going
to assume if I run
get
QVDN.
I was not
ready yet.
At this point, it should
be ready enough that if you
retrieve that cube config secret, you can query
that
control plan and see the status.
So is there a convenience way of getting
that, or do I SSH back into that
machine?
So if you look back at the quick
start, there's a Oh. Set of commands in
there.
Right down there, the the
oh, I forgot. We added a
a friendly command
to retrieve the Kube config with ClusterCuddle.
So let's we can give that a shot.
Oh, wait. No. It that version hasn't released
yet, so let's let's run the workaround.
Ah, yes. Zero three nine. Okay.
Oh. Correct. I need to That command and
the warning there should be Oh, alright. Okay.
Okay. So
this is the painful way. That's the nice
way that just doesn't exist yet. Got it.
Yep.
Painful
is okay. Painful. So
I need to
rename this
to livestream.
Let's see if it config admin.
Was it livestream two for that cluster?
It was.
I just did not and that looks good.
So if I do cube
config equals
do I have to cat it or is
it path? I can never remember.
I
cat is the safe way.
And I think it's I don't think there's
an underscore in there, if I'm not mistaken.
Get
all.
Yeah. I found it. Okay. So
Oh,
yeah. It needs the path there. Sorry.
Long day.
I say it. 10:56 in the morning. Right?
And at this point, you can
I was gonna say, at this point, you
can use that kube config to deploy the
CNI, and then we should see everything
become ready and and everything else spin up?
Got it. Okay. So we're not gonna rock
the boat too much here, and we're oh,
that's that's keep coming right
in front of me. Okay. So
let's
do this. I'll just keep doing it with
the environment variables since it works.
So I guess that's pulling images right now
for
the things that it needs.
And and if you go back to the
the management cluster and run
get cluster API, you should see some of
those additional resources start spinning up.
We
have
oh, that's the old control plan
or new control plan.
We have an initialized
control plan.
Good.
Is our provisioning.
I guess we just give that another moment.
Yeah. It might take a little bit for
it to realize that it's
Yep. Alright. So we have our our workers
are very much on their way. That's good.
So let's step back, Rose, while
is that it? Does it work?
Yeah. I mean, now you can,
I I would probably wait until everything finishes
deploying? But then at that point, you can
go ahead and deploy
any types of workloads you need to the
workload cluster.
Awesome.
K. So let's run our cluster API once
more.
We got lots of ready machines.
Our control plane now says ready.
I'm assuming this is If
you see the control plane's also on its
way to scaling up to three replicas as
well,
and it'll scale up got an AJ control
plane as well.
Yep.
Okay.
She's getting interesting.
Not that it wasn't interesting, of course. Does
it configure SCD backups for me as well?
That would be pretty sweet.
It does not.
You know, we we had talked about it,
but even if you do SCD backups, it
doesn't necessarily guarantee the state of your,
you know, cluster being in a good state,
especially once you start throwing in persistent volumes
and things like that. So we generally recommend
folks use some type of Kubernetes specific backup
utility against their workload clusters if there's data
that they care about, whether it's
something like
Valero or or, you know, anything else in
that space.
Okay.
I don't know whether I should just be
patient or I should just keep poking at
things. But
And it's just gonna take a little bit
of time because we are dealing with,
you know, bare metal servers that take a
little bit more time to come up. And
then the way the packet provider is doing
the bootstrapping,
you know, downloading all the binaries on the
fly takes a little bit longer.
Yeah. I mean, we do
we have seen that our control plane is
scaling up, and we have got worker machines
being deployed. That's pretty awesome.
So
let's go back to
this cluster.
When
I get when I run git all, I
was expecting to see some sort of could
proxy Calico pods.
Because I'm not good on namespaces. Right?
Silly me.
So we do have
that's cool.
Okay. Perfect.
Could also run some, like,
kubectl get nodes on there. And,
generally, if things are in the process of
bootstrapping,
you can see,
you know, part of the progress there as
well.
So it does say that my
worker nodes are ready.
So I guess I can deploy something.
Yeah.
Let's go with index.
Resource
on it.
That
should be okay. So I can do oh,
I need my special config.
I
Internet.
If I get bugs.
Let's take a watch on oh, we'll find
a watch if it's already running.
So
I see we do have a question out
there too.
Ah, cool.
Oh, wait. Pocket fence.
That's how I learn, I mean, I I
I just type as many describe commands and
edit commands as I can until I know
what's going on. So okay.
So
we have a question. Does Cluster API
orchestrate Kubernetes upgrades?
And yes. Yes. It does.
That's one of the things that we introduced
with v one alpha three with the cube
ADM control plane.
We've always been able to orchestrate the upgrades
of machine deployments because we have the declarative
config there.
You can't necessarily do this in a very
good way with the packet provider because as
you've seen, the way that we kinda bootstrap
causes some issues with it. But assuming that
wasn't an issue, you can basically just upgrade
or update the version on the machine deployment,
and it would orchestrate the rolling update of
those worker nodes.
But with v one alpha three, when we
introduced kubatem control plane,
that also provides the same mechanism there.
Does it do is it an in place
upgrade, or is it terminate and then reprovision
on new machines?
It does not actually do an in place
upgrade.
We wanted to avoid some of the complexity
there.
So what it does is it will spin
up a new
instance.
It will run kubeadm
join to join the existing
control plane instances, and then it will
remove one of the existing ones, and it
will continue on that until it's made it
through all the replicas.
So in a bare mail configuration
sorry. So is that upgrading the control plane
or just the worker nodes?
Both with the default configuration,
it will
assuming you upgrade both you know, upgrade
the definition on the machine machine deployment and
the Kubernetes control plane,
it's the same process. It will surge up
for the replacement
and then,
you know, remove instances
along the way.
So I'm assuming it's waiting till SED is
is replicated there to the new
notes and then strips them back down. Okay.
Correct. Yep. Yeah. We wait until,
ETCD is in a healthy state. We also
verify that,
the static pod manifest for the controller manager,
the scheduler,
and the API server
are in a good state before we kind
of continue in the process.
Yeah. You're pretty much removing all the pain
from every Kubernetes upgrade I've ever done in
my entire life. So
so this is exciting for me.
Now I did try to do a port
forward to my engine x pod.
I'm not sure why that wouldn't work.
Alright.
It's not that important. I can oh, I'm
getting pod not banned.
Well, it's to be like, it was
then expose it over a service or just
a service prefix.
It's just me being,
you know, a better than an idiot.
That's okay.
Awesome.
That was amazing. Thank you very much.
Thank you. I now know what the Cluster
API
does, and I've now spun up my own
Kubernetes cluster on packet. That is pretty sweet.
And then you can start getting into some,
you know, fun down the line. You can
throw in things like the cluster autoscaler into
the mix and start automating scaling of these
clusters as well.
So
the I can run the cluster autoscaler
to
add new nodes when, what, CPU and memory
get above a certain threshold,
etcetera.
By by default, with the kind of
cluster API
integration for Cluster Autoscaler, what it'll do is
it'll look at
the scheduling constraints
of the workload cluster. So
if you have any pods that are pending,
it'll try to determine how many resources it
needs to spin up for there so it'll
scale up your machine deployments appropriately for you.
And then if you start ending up with
too much
excess resources,
it'll start scaling those resources back down.
Okay.
Okay. Well, I don't I don't wanna take
up too much more of your time by
installing that. That's not deployed by default. Right?
That's an add on that I would then
add to my cluster. Okay. Then I think
you've just, you know, verbally agreed to do
another session with me when we dig into
some of the extra features and of the
cluster API and the other scaler. So, you
know, thanks for that.
Yeah. We can definitely do that.
We we'll need to wait till some of
the
the changes are
you know, that are currently in flight land
because right now, you would need kind of
like a self hosted cluster API cluster to
make it work. So,
you know, once those changes land, then you'll
be able to run, you know, multiple autoscalers
and manage multiple workload clusters,
you know, within a single management cluster.
Very, very cool.
Alright. Is there anything else you would like
to share with people before we finish up
for the this afternoon of the morning for
yourself?
Not that I can think of. It's been
a pleasure to, work through this with you
today. No. Thank you very much for joining
me. It was really interesting to walk through
that and just see how it all works
and, you know, be able to ask those
questions to someone who's really close to this
is just, you know, invaluable. So, you know,
thank you again.
I'm looking forward to future updates, and I
can't wait to see where this goes. So
again, thank you for joining me. Have a
nice day, and I will speak to you
soon.
Adios.